boy oh boy am i excited to show you why
we haven't started today yes ninja has
sent us something pretty awesome and no
it's not a gaming pc no it's not some
kind of server
it is
geek eats is back baby and boy am i
hungry now we tested the philips
airfryer double xl and i gotta say that
was one of our favorite air fryers
because it can hold 7.3 liters of food
you could literally fit in a whole
chicken
and feed your whole family even your
extended family but ninja takes it a
step further by including a 7.6 liter
cooking capacity all thanks to not one
but two independent baskets so they can
cook two dishes in two different ways at
the same time that that is just
mind-boggling man that's so cool meet
the ninja dual zone air fryer it's got
so many standout features that are sure
to tantalize your taste buds and feed
your family at the same time so let's
take a look at price and availability
the ninja foodie dual zone airfryer
comes in at a whopping 399 singapore
dollars it's a little bit pricey or
199.99 us dollars for the 7.6 liter or 8
quad model which we have right here now
for those who need an even larger
capacity they do have the 9 liter or 10
quad model available but only in the us
going for
299.99 us dollars with that if you're
planning to get this for yourself do
check out the links in our description
below now this airfryer boasts a nice
black finish with some chrome trimming
as well it's gonna fit in any kitchen on
any counter top now because this is
essentially two airfryers in one
you're gonna expect a larger size so
bear in mind that this is actually quite
a large kitchen appliance for your
countertop then again you know might as
well just throw out your current air
fryer you won't be needing that
moving over to build quality man i gotta
tell you ninja doesn't sell itself short
all right this thing is really hefty
weighing about 8.3 kilograms or about 18
pounds very very well made and i love
the handles it just feels so good in
hand and they slide out very smoothly so
you have no problems with that
so with the cooking tray it comes with a
crisper plate and what this crisper
plate does is it helps to brown the food
on top of that it prevents food from
sticking at the bottom of the tray and
with the holes here it helps to
circulate the heat to remove excess
moisture from the food as well very easy
to wash and the best part is that it's
dishwasher safe so then let's get to
some cooking
now the ninja foodie dual zone airfryer
has a few cool features here on the
digital control panel we've got max
crips airfry roast reheat dehydrate and
bake as i mentioned before you've got
two different zones here so you also
have two different displays so we got
tray one here and tray two as well
and each being able to control the
timers
and the temperatures independently now
we've also got a sink and match button
all right so i'm just gonna load up some
fries
on both baskets
tray one
three two
okay we're gonna match the settings so
we're gonna go for the max crisp
function which is the highest
temperature we have which is 240 degrees
celsius or about 460 degrees fahrenheit
then we're going to set the time
for let's go for 15 minutes as per
recommended and then we're gonna click
match
so tray 1 and 2 will have the same
temperatures and and at the same time so
let's go
despite this bigger size one might
assume that it's going to sound a lot
louder but it actually sounds like any
other ordinary air fryer
now all we gotta do is wait while we
wait we must also wait in comfort with
secret land this video is brought to you
by secret lab here at geek culture we
love our circuit
especially the all-new 2022 titan evo
with its revamped 4-way lumbar system
for enhanced back support if pu leather
2.0 isn't your cup of tea then consider
the all-new soft weave even more soft
and breathable than before the chair
comes in more colours including this
lovely frost blue the tyson evo is even
magnetized allowing the hit pillow to
stick on the headrest of course there
are even more new features so do check
them out at secretlab.co
i guess one caveat i can think of is
that this airfryer does not alert you to
shake the tray once in a while
but hey it's not really big of a deal
you know
as long as it turns out crispy
oh is it done
it's done yay
and we didn't use oil in this
oh wow actually there's not much oil in
the tray cool
all right guys air fried frozen fries at
max crisp setting
i could go on and on
got our carbs done let's move on to some
proteins now let's just see if one of
the baskets could fit an entire chicken
i got like a four or five pounder here
marinated it a little bit with some
peri-peri sauce and i'm just gonna coat
it in oil just add the oil inside this
pot here all right will it fit
yes it will oh that's hot too man
here's some stuff for you guys
chicken in the first tray
and in tray two we're gonna have a
salmon inside
fresh salmon we're gonna lightly coat it
with some
oil first just so we can get a nice sear
oh that's a lot of oil okay and then
we're gonna sprinkle it with some salt
now this is some lazy man cooking so
you know my methods aren't exactly the
best some black pepper too okay
there we go airfryer guys okay tray two
all right so we got our chicken and
airfryer loaded in let's start with tray
one which has the chicken inside we're
gonna set it to roast at 190 sounds very
good we're gonna
start off with 30 minutes and see from
there
and trade to the salmon we're gonna have
it to
roast at 210
right
for
only eight minutes
that should work so if you want both of
them to go out at the same time all we
need to do is click at the sink button
now it lights up
so because the chicken takes longer to
cook it's gonna start the chicken first
it's going to hold on the salmon
and once it reaches the 8-minute mark
for the chicken then the salmon starts
to cook
that's the power of the sink button man
and it's going to come out at the same
time so let's go
you can see right here the salmon is on
hold while we wait for the chicken
awesome all right now you can see that
it's eight minutes down seven is also
eight minutes and it's gonna unhold
there we go and the salmon is starting
to cook
there we have it folks
chicken and salmon done at the same time
whoo all right gonna fish this bad boy
oh yo yo yo look there's still smoke and
steam coming out of this a salmon
solid
check that out guys
[Music]
it
is yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
look at that dude
flaky
perfectly cooked
[Music]
[Applause]
all right our chicken is done salmon is
done we gotta top it off with some
garlic bread
fans oh wow
we were using the big function for this
honestly speaking
if you don't have space for grill
the airfryer can do so much wonders just
got a nice meat platter here for i think
of a sunday brunch kind of thing
i'm gonna add some salmon
at this point i don't really care that
we're making a mess because it feels so
good there you have it my geeks
quick simple easy
make your dishes in half the time
because you got two airfryers with the
ninja foodie dual zone airfryer
what else is there to say you looked at
the food you see how it came out to
perfection i'm a total mess
don't judge me i'm enjoying myself it's
simply outstanding it's got great
features that really maximizes your
creativity when it comes to your cooking
experience will it replace your pots
pans your stove maybe even your oven
yeah maybe yes maybe not but it is a
great addition to your kitchen what do
you think of the ninja foodie dual zone
air fryer what do you think about the
price let us know your thoughts down in
the comments below and while you're down
there do give us like and subscribe
thank you for watching this video and
until next time this is zaki adios
[Music]